Marc is still out. David, you're leading the architecture discussion today. Three items on the agenda?
Right. Deployment model as we scale, service-to-service communication, and repository structure for the new hires starting in July.
I want to make sure we're building something the team can actually operate. What's the deployment model you're proposing?
Kubernetes. Specifically, EKS as our primary cluster on AWS. For disaster recovery and load distribution, we add a GCP GKE cluster as a secondary.
Walk me through the DR story. What actually happens if EKS has an outage?
Traffic shifts to GKE automatically via DNS failover. RTO under fifteen minutes. The databases stay on AWS RDS — we're only moving compute. Failover gets pre-tested monthly.
What does this mean for the engineers we're hiring? Do they need Kubernetes expertise going in?
Yes, and that's intentional. Kubernetes is the industry standard now. Any senior backend engineer we hire should know it. I'm treating it as a filter in the interview process.
I'm comfortable with that. Léa?
Fine from a product standpoint. As long as rollouts stay invisible to customers, I don't care about the plumbing.
Agreed. We'll run EKS as primary with a GCP GKE cluster for disaster recovery. Standard Kubernetes everywhere.
Decision: Kubernetes-based multi-cloud deployment, EKS primary, GCP GKE for disaster recovery. David owns the cluster setup. I'll have the first cluster running in the staging environment by end of sprint.
Good. Service-to-service communication. We have four services scoped for the first half of the year. What's the model?
Istio as the service mesh. Mutual TLS between services automatically, circuit breaking, traffic shaping. We get observability for free — no custom middleware.
Does Istio add latency? I remember it coming up in a past conversation as a concern.
A few milliseconds per hop in the worst case, negligible against database roundtrips. The security and observability gains are worth it by a wide margin.
Decision: Istio for inter-service traffic. David owns the initial configuration.
Last item: repository structure. We're about to onboard two engineers. Monorepo or polyrepo?
My instinct is monorepo. Shared libraries, atomic commits across services, easier code review — especially at our size.
I agree. We use Turborepo for the build layer. It handles caching and dependency graphs well. New engineers can clone one repo and be running in an hour.
Monorepo makes sense. Polyrepo gets complicated fast when you have shared models between services and no one knows which repo has the canonical version.
Agreed. Monorepo with Turborepo for builds. David sets it up before the new hires start. That's all three. Good session.
I'll have a draft architecture doc for Marc to review next week. He'll want to see the Kubernetes plan before we go too far.
I'll send him a summary of the decisions so he's not blindsided when he's back.
Good. I'll brief him one-on-one before the team sees the architecture doc.